>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Kahin Mohammad: Well,
my name is Kahin Mohammad,
and I'm a program specialist
here at the Library
of Congress's Young Reading Center.
And I want to thank you
all for coming here today.
Oyster-Adams is a really
big friend of ours
and we're appreciative
of you coming out.
I also want to thank
Tulane University,
Vanderbilt University class, also
Center for the Book, and the Library
of Congress as well
for hosting us today.
We're very, very pleased to have
Duncan here to read his book
and also discuss with you all today
a very important subject matter
and topic, and we'll
hope you'll enjoy it.
So thank you.
And we'll have a question-answer
session at the very end.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Hi, everybody.
Good morning.
Buenas dias.
So my name is Duncan Tonatiuh.
And I write and I illustrate
children's books.
And so this is one of
the books I've made.
And so what I thought I'd do is I
will go over it quickly for those
of you that don't know the book, and
then I want to show you a little bit
of the process of making the book.
Tell you a little bit more
of why I wrote the book
and show you some other pictures.
And I want to make sure I give
you guys time to ask questions.
Maybe I'll show you some of my
other books if we have time.
Does that sound good?
>> Yes.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: So
the other book is called
"Separate is Never
Equal, Sylvia Mendez
and Her Family's Fight
for Desegregation."
And this story is a true story.
It happened about 70 years ago.
And so it starts here and this
is the first page and we see
that Sylvia, right, she's very sad,
and it's her first day
at this new school.
But a boy, a white boy, points at
her and says, you don't belong here,
go back to the Mexican school.
And so Sylvia doesn't want to
talk with anybody that day.
And when she comes home from
school, she tells her mom, mom,
I don't want to go to school
that anymore, the kids are mean.
And her mom says, Sylvia,
[foreign language].
What does that mean?
Yeah, don't you know
that is why we fought.
And so then Sylvia remembers
all that had to happen
so that she could go to that school.
So she remembers how she moved from
the city of Santa Ana in California
to the town of Westminster.
And in this town, her
family was leasing a farm.
And in the farm they were going to
grow asparagus, tomatoes, chilies.
And then because summer was
almost over, Sylvia's aunt,
her aunt Soledad, drove
Sylvia and her brothers
and also her cousin's Alice and
Virginia to the local public school
so they could attend
school when it started.
And they went there and Sylvia
thought it was a really nice school.
It had those tall trees
in the front.
There was a nice playground
in the back.
And when she went in there, when
they went in there, her aunt talked
to the secretary at the
school, and she said,
I'm here to bring my daughters
Alice and Virginia to the school
and also my niece Sylvia and
my nephews, Gonzalo and Jerome.
And the secretary said,
your daughters Alice
and Virginia can come to the
school, but Sylvia and her brothers,
they cannot come to the school.
They have to go to
the Mexican school.
And Sylvia was very
confused when she said that.
She said, why do I have
to go to a Mexican school?
I'm a US citizen.
I was born here in
the United States.
My father's from Mexico
but he became a US citizen.
My mom is from Puerto Rico
which is a US territory.
So why do I have to go
to a Mexican school?
And that she wondered if it was
because of the color of her skin,
or because her last name was Mendez.
And so her aunt told her that,
talked to the secretary, and said,
but we all live in
this part of town,
all the students should be
allowed to go school together.
And the secretary said, no.
The Mendez children have to
go to the Mexican school.
So her aunt told her that and
said, I won't be enrolling any
of the students at this school then.
And so she drove back to the
farm and told Sylvia's father,
Gonzalo, what had happened.
And he said, oh, it must
be a misunderstanding.
I'll go talk with the
principal or the superintendent
or someone at the school.
So he talked with the
superintendent,
a man named Mr. Atkinson.
But Mr. Atkinson said
the same thing.
The Mendez children have to
go to the Mexican school.
And Mr. Mendez asked, but why?
And Mr. Atkinson said,
that's the way it's done.
The Mendez children have to
go to the Mexican school.
So that fall, Sylvia
and her brothers had
to go to the Mexican school.
And the school was on Olive Street,
and everyone called that school
on Olive Street the Mexican
school because that's
where all the children
of Mexican parents
or all the Latino children
were sent.
And the school was
a clapboard shack.
It did not have any --
there was no playground.
The students had to
eat their lunch outside
and it was next to a cow pasture.
And that fence that kept the cows
in the pasture had
electricity running through it.
So if any of the kids touched
it, they would receive a shock.
But the worst thing
about the school was
that the teachers there didn't
care about the students' education,
because they thought
they would all drop
out by the time they
were in eighth grade.
They thought that they
would stop going to school
and they would just start
working in the fields.
So they didn't really pay
attention to their education.
And Sylvia's family didn't
think that that was fair.
Her parents didn't
think that was fair.
Sylvia didn't think
that that was fair.
So her father decided to write
a petition, write a letter,
saying that all children should be
allowed to go to school together.
And he tried to get other
parents that had children
in the Mexican school to sign it,
but the other parents were scared
to sign it because they
thought they would get
in trouble or lose their jobs.
Because their bosses were white.
So they didn't want
to sign the petition.
But Sylvia's father didn't give
up, and he kept talking to people.
And one day a truck driver that went
to his farm to pick produce told him
about a man named Mr. Marcus.
And Mr. Marcus was a lawyer,
and he had helped the people
of a nearby city, in the
city of San Bernardino,
to desegregate the public pool.
Because at that time
not only in the '40s --
this story takes place in the '40s.
Not only were schools divided but
also other places, like parks,
public pools, movie theaters.
And children like Mexican
American children
or African-American children,
Asian-American children
were not allowed to use them
or were only allowed to use them on
certain days or only certain parts.
And so Mr. Mendez decided
that he was going to hire
that man Mr. Marcus even if he had
to spend all his savings to do so.
So that he would help them
desegregate the school and make it
so that all the Mexican
American children go to school
with the other children,
with white children.
And so Mr. Mendez and Mr.
Marcus started traveling
to the different towns
and cities in the county,
in a county named Orange County.
And they talked with other families.
Because it wasn't only Sylvia and
her brothers that weren't allowed
to go -- that were sent to Mexican
schools, but there were thousands
of children in the area that
were sent to the Mexican schools.
And so while Sylvia's father
traveled around trying
to get more families involved
in the case, Sylvia's mother had
to do all the things that I
Sylvia's father usually did.
Her mother, Felicitas, had to drive
a tractor and take care of the farm
and do all the things
that he usually did.
And Mr. Mendez was able to get
different families involved
in the case, like the Strata family.
And Mr. Strata, he had fought
in World War II for the US Army.
But when he came back, he saw that
his children weren't allowed to go
to school, that they were
sent to a separate school.
So he didn't think
that that was fair.
So he decided to join the case.
And several more families of
the different cities and towns
in Orange County joined the case.
And on March 2, 1945, the lawyer,
Mr. Marcus, went to a courthouse
in Los Angeles and filed a lawsuit.
And so what that meant is
that the different families
and different superintendents and
teachers from the schools would come
to a room, a room like this
or even larger than this.
And at the front, there would
be a judge who would listen
and the different lawyers would
ask people to come to the stand.
And so, for example,
on the first day,
Mr. Marcus called to
the stand Mr. Kent.
And Mr. Kent was in charge --
was the superintendent from
one of the schools in the area.
And he asked him several questions.
He said, why do you send the
Mexican-American children
to a different school?
And he said, oh, it's
because they don't know how
to how to speak English.
And Sylvia was very upset when
he said that because she knew how
to speak English perfectly well.
And no one had asked
her or given her a test
to see if she spoke English.
So that was not true.
And then Mr. Marcus
kept asking questions.
And then Mr. Kent started saying
some very mean things, like that --
he said that the Mexican
children always have problems.
They were always dirty.
They always have dirty
hands, face, neck, and ears.
That they were inferior in their
ability to behave and their ability
to learn and their ability
to participate in the school.
And so the Mendez family was very
upset when he said all those things.
But it was -- but those things that
Mr. Kent said were things that a lot
of people at the time believed
and had that same attitude.
And so the trial continued
for several more days.
And so every day different people
were asked to come up to the stand
and they were asked questions.
And so, for example, Sylvia's
father came up to the stand
and Sylvia's mother and Mr.
Atkinson from Sylvia's school.
And Sylvia herself was
not called to the stand
because she was still young,
she was like eight years old.
But a girl that was a little
older, named Carol Torres,
was asked to come to the stand.
And she proved that she
spoke English perfectly well
and that it was not true
that she was being --
that the Mexican-American
children were being sent
to a different school
because of language.
And then they also asked questions
to some college professors,
some education specialists,
that said that it was
bad to divide children.
Because then it makes
one group feel superior
and one group feel inferior, and
that children should be allowed
to go to school all together.
And so the judge had to listen
to all these things, right,
and then he had to
decide who was right.
Whether the school board, the
people from the schools were right,
or whether the families,
like the Mendez family
and the other families involved
in the case, were right.
And so he took almost a year
to decide, but he decided
that the Mendez family and the other
Mexican-American families were right
and that all children should
go to school together.
And so the Mendez family
was very happy,
and the news appeared
in local newspapers.
But they didn't have much time
to celebrate because the people
in charge of the schools
appealed the case.
And what that means is they ask a
different judge that has more power
to review the case,
because they were hoping
that he would change the decision.
So this time, a judge in San
Francisco, in Northern California --
because this was happening
in Southern California --
had to review the case and had
to decide whether the Mendez
family should win again
or whether the schools should win.
But this time while he was
deciding, different organizations
that represented different kinds
of people in different parts
of the United States started
sending letters to the judge
so that he would favor
the Mendez family.
And so, for example, the National
Association for the Advancement
of Colored People, the
Japanese-American Citizens League,
the American-Jewish Congress,
and other organizations
sent these letters.
And on April 15, 1947, the
judge in the Court of Appeal
in San Francisco decided that the
Mendez family should win again.
And that June, the Governor of
California signed a law that said
that all children in
California were allowed to go
to school together regardless
of race, ethnicity, or language.
And so here is Sylvia, and it's
her second day at the school.
And do you remember when we
first started the story, right,
that's her first day at school.
And she remembers all of this,
all the things that had to happen
so she could go to that school,
to the Westminster school.
And so the second day at school, she
doesn't listen to any of the kids
that say mean things to her.
And she realized that other
kids want to be nice to her
and want to be her friend.
And by the end of the
year, she makes a friend.
And by the end of the school year,
she makes lots of friends of --
and she's friends with kids of
different backgrounds and races.
And she's very proud to
be attending that school
because her family fought
very hard to make that happen.
And that's the end of the book.
Do you guys like it?
>> Yes.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: And like I
said, this story, it's a true story.
So here's a picture of Sylvia
when she was about 10 years old.
And this is a picture of Sylvia
a few years ago, in 2011,
when she received a medal.
Do you see here that she has
a medal, she received a medal
from President Obama for
all her courage and all
that her family accomplished.
And here's a picture of Sylvia's
father and Sylvia's mother
and that's a picture of
the Westminster school
that she was not allowed to go to.
And that's the school
on Olive Street
that everyone called the Mexican
school that she had to go to.
Do you guys have any
thoughts or questions so far?
Yeah.
>> Do you know Sylvia Mendez?
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Yeah.
So I had the chance
to meet Sylvia Mendez.
So this story I think is
a very important story,
but not a lot of people
know about it.
I didn't learn about
it till recently.
I learned about it like
three or four years ago.
And there's -- raise your hand if
you've heard of Martin Luther King.
Okay, put your hands down.
Raise your hand if you've
heard of Cesar Chavez.
Okay, a few of you.
Raise your hand if you've heard of
Brown versus Board of Education.
Okay, just a couple of you.
So there's some civil rights
leaders, right, there's people
that sometimes you learn in
school, like Martin Luther King,
which most of you have heard
about, that fought to bring justice
and equality in the United
States so that people
of different races could live
and have the same opportunities.
But there's a lot of other
people that also fought for that
that you may not learn
about or hear as often.
And so Sylvia's family
is one of these cases.
And there's a similar case
that happened seven years
after all this happened
and involved a girl,
an African-American girl,
that lived in Kansas.
That also like Sylvia, she was
not allowed to go to the school,
to the public school,
that was near her house,
but she had to go much farther away
to a different school that was only
for African-American children.
And her family didn't think that
this was fair and they fought
and eventually that helped
make it so that all children
in the United States could
go to school together.
And some of the people that were
involved in that second case,
that's very famous and that
some of you may learn about,
were first involved in this case,
like the Governor of California.
He became a judge in that case.
And, for example, Thurgood Marshall,
who was the lawyer in that case,
he sent letters for this
case, for the Mendez case.
So going back to what
you asked, I only learned
about this story a few years ago.
And I was at a book festival in
Texas, and Sylvia Mendez was there.
And I had just learned about the
case, so I had a chance to talk
with her and ask her questions.
And so a lot of things in the book
come from talking with her directly.
And other things in the book
come from doing research
and reading different books and
reading different articles about it.
Do you have a question?
>> Is Sylvia Mendez still alive?
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Yes.
So let me show you guys
some other pictures.
How do I exit this, do you know?
Like make it small.
So let me show you some more
pictures from the time period.
And I'll show you a
picture of Sylvia nowadays.
Can you press down shift, please.
So here's a picture
of Sylvia's parents,
a picture of Sylvia's mother.
And so, you know, I looked at
these pictures and that's how --
for my drawings, I tried to --
hopefully they look a
little bit like them.
That's the school that everyone
called the Mexican school.
That's Sylvia's parents.
Sylvia's father.
Sylvia's father and mother.
That's Sylvia and her
two brothers and a nanny.
That's her a few years ago.
That's her when she
was 11 years old.
That's her aunt Soledad,
that drove her to the school.
That is the Westminster school.
And that's a picture of Sylvia
a few years ago when I met her
and when I had a chance
to ask her questions.
So she's still alive, and she
travels off to different parts
in the United States
and talks about the case
and about education
with different students.
She is -- I forget her rage now --
but she's going to turn 80 soon.
But she's a very active woman.
And she's very nice
and very friendly.
Yes? Let me bring you the mic.
>> Are you the author
and the illustrator?
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Yes.
So I am the author
and the illustrator.
And so I want to ask you guys
a few questions about that.
Well, here I just want to
show you this really quick.
So, like I said, I talked
with Sylvia and that was one
of the ways that I wrote this story.
But I also learned when people
go to court, there's a secretary,
there's someone that types
everything that people say.
And so, for example, here, I
was able to read transcripts
of all the things that
were said during the case.
And you can see here what Mr. Marcus
said, Mr. Holden who was the lawyer
for the school board, and
all the different questions
and all the different
things that they asked.
I read through that, and then
after reading some of those things,
I used that for the story.
I included some of
that in the story.
But if we go back here,
I made drawings.
And I want to see if you guys
notice anything -- let me go to --
do you guys see how when I made my
drawings, they're always in profile?
What does that mean?
Profiles, they're always
looking to the side.
We never see them looking
with both eyes straight ahead.
And do you guys notice anything else
that strikes you about the drawings?
Let's hear over here.
[inaudible response] I have
pictures in the drawings, okay.
Anything else?
Over here.
[inaudible response] Well, let's go
back to your question in a moment.
But does anybody else
perceive anything different
or unusual about these drawings?
Over here.
[inaudible response].
Okay. Yeah, yeah, maybe like
in this image, for example.
Let me find it.
Like here, right, their
body is facing one way
but their head is facing
another, kind of.
And does anybody notice anything
interesting about their ears?
Their ears look a little bit like a
number three or a letter E, right?
Does anybody -- why do you guys
think I make my drawings like that?
Anybody want to take a guess?
Let's see, maybe over there.
Yeah. [inaudible] Okay, to make it
more creative, that's part of it.
Anybody else?
Here. [inaudible] To
make it more real.
All right, so let me show you some
drawings that inspire my drawings.
And these are drawings that
people made about 500 years ago.
So these drawings are drawings
that the Mixtec people made.
And the Mixtec were an indigenous
group from the South of Mexico.
And they would make their own books.
And in their books,
they told their stories
about their kings and the warriors.
And you can see that
in the drawings,
people are always in profile.
They're always looking to the side.
And the ears, you can see here,
that sometimes look a little
bit like the number three.
And you can see that the hands
are often kind of like this like
or like this or like that.
And so I looked at those things
and I thought that this art
that people made hundreds of
years ago was very interesting,
very creative.
And I kind of wanted to
do something similar,
make drawings that are similar to
those, but make them about stories
that are happening now or that
happened in the recent past.
So we go back to the book, maybe
you can see, you know, how the ears
or the eyes or here maybe the hands,
I try and do it similar
to that style.
But then like you guys have noticed,
then I also used pictures --
let's find a large image.
And I used different textures.
Have you guys ever made a collage?
Raise your hand if
you've made a collage.
Okay, you can put your hands down.
So a collage is when you
cut different types of paper
or maybe pictures from magazines
or maybe different types of cloths,
and you glue it all
together to make a new image.
So I do something like that
but I do it in the computer.
And so I graph, for example, this
brown paper, and that's one texture.
And then, for example, this here,
her skirt is a different texture,
and, for example, her shoes.
Maybe I'll take a picture of
something like a leather seat
and then I'll use part of that
picture to make her shoes.
And that's how I make
the illustrations.
[inaudible] Yes, so you
can see the hair here.
So what that is -- I don't
have my own computer here,
otherwise I'd show you how I do it.
But it's a picture, like I can
take a picture of someone's hair
or I find a picture of someone's
hair or a wig on the Internet,
and then I cut it out and glue it
there, that's basically what I do.
But I do it in the computer
so it's a little neater.
Because I'm kind of
a messy, messy guy,
so I just use glue and scissors.
Other questions?
Let's see, over here?
Maybe they're going to
pass you the microphone.
>> How do you make the pictures?
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Well, how about
I draw on a piece of paper, right,
just like a letter-size
regular piece of paper.
I make a drawing with a pencil.
So let's say I draw Sylvia.
And then after I like the
drawing, I go over it with a pen.
And after I draw with a pen, I
use a machine called a scanner.
A scanner is a bit like
a photocopy machine.
And you put it on top
of the scanner.
And there's a cable connected to the
computer and it goes [makes sounds].
And so then the drawing that I
did on a piece of paper appears
on the screen, like
on a computer screen.
And then on the computer screen,
I put the different textures
and different colors on it.
But what I want to do now is
show you how I make a book,
because it's related
to what you asked.
How long do you guys think
it takes to make a book?
[inaudible].
Any idea? How long do you think
it takes me to make a book?
[inaudible] 30 what?
30 minutes?
Okay, let's see.
Someone else, over there?
>> Maybe a month or four weeks.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Okay,
a month or four weeks.
Let's see, back there?
Yeah?
>> A year maybe.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: A year maybe.
Okay, so usually it takes
me about six months,
sometimes closer to a year.
And so the first thing I do is, you
know, I have an idea for a story,
I write it out, and then
I send it to an editor.
An editor is a person kind of
like a teacher, who reads it
and then gives me comments and
says, oh, okay, this is very good,
but I'm not sure what's going
on here, or I don't know
if the ending is very good or what
happened in this part of the story.
So you know, so what I wrote,
for example, here is in black.
And all these things
in green are things
that he changed or
had questions about.
So you can see that it never
comes up perfect the first time.
I write it out and then the
editor crosses out all sorts
of things and has questions.
And, you know, often in the
side here he'll put questions,
like but what happened to Aunt
Solidad or what did she do
after she took the
kids to the school.
So you can see -- so
that's the first part,
I write the story,
and then I revise it.
I send it back and forth with this
editor, like four or five times
at least, till we're both
very happy with the story.
And then after that -- and so that
usually takes me about two months,
sometimes more, till we're
both very happy with the story.
And then after that, I make
sketches for the entire book.
I draw just in black and
white, the entire book.
So you can see there, that was
my first idea for the cover.
And the cover changed.
And then here, you know, that's
the first page in the book.
And here a different person,
called an art director,
she or he gives me comments and
says, oh, but maybe move this
because you forgot to include this.
Like maybe she should have
lunch, a lunch bag or a backpack,
or maybe move the text a little
bit because it won't fit.
You know, like here it says maybe
I should move it up a little
because otherwise it's
going to be too [inaudible].
Yeah, so I get a lot
of these comments.
And so they've now changed
the sketches many times also.
And that usually takes me
like two or three months.
And then after that, after both
the art director and I are happy
with the book, with the drawings,
then I put the different
texture and color in the books.
Any other questions?
You have a question?
[inaudible].
Am I already happy with the book?
Yeah, I'm very happy with this book.
One reason why I decided
-- I made this book for --
I had two big reasons
to make this book.
So the first reason is that I
think it's an important piece
of American history that not
a lot of people know about.
I think it's an important story
that I think more people
should learn about.
Because, like I said,
sometimes kids in school learn
about important civil rights
leaders, like Martin Luther King
or Cesar Chavez, but there were also
other people that also fought hard
to bring positive change,
create positive change
in the United States, in America,
and not a lot of people
know their stories.
So I thought that this story
was important for that.
But the other reason is that,
you know, because I'm an author
and illustrator and I write
books, sometimes I get invited
to visit different schools
in the United States
in different parts
of the United States.
And sometimes I see that schools
continue to be very divided.
Like sometimes if I go to a school
that's in a poor neighborhood
or poor area, it's
usually Latino children
and African-American children
that go to that school.
And if I go to a school
that's maybe in a suburb
where there's more money, it tends
to be mostly white
children or Anglo children.
So a lot of the problems that Sylvia
was having 70 years ago are still
kind of happening today.
So I thought that was another
reason why I should write this book
and why maybe some of you
will relate to this story.
You have a question?
>> Yeah. So how do you fit
the texture onto the picture?
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: So
I do it in the computer
and then gets printed by a printer.
But when they print the book,
they print thousands of copies.
So it actually gets printed
by large, large machines
that print thousands of copies
of the book and it gets bound.
So I don't do that
myself personally,
it gets printed by machines.
And so it takes me like six months
or a year to make the book, right.
But then after I finish the book,
it takes like another six months
for the book to come out,
because it gets printed
by those large machines, then it has
to be shipped in boats or airplanes
or trucks, be sent to different
stores, to different libraries.
And before the book comes out,
they usually send some free copies
to different librarians or teachers
or people that write for magazines
so that they will read the book
and say, oh, it's a good book,
people should buy it, people should
have it in their school library
or in their public library.
So from the time that I first have
the idea for the book till the time
that someone is actually
holding and reading the book,
it takes at least a year, sometimes
more like a year and a half or two.
Yes, do you have a question?
>> Well, I think you guys remember
that Ms. Kleinman has been
telling you all that I've been
on this award committee, right.
I've been telling you
probably since last year.
And I think I've showed some
of you some of the books
that we were reading and picking
and thinking about carefully,
to see which books we were going
to decide got this very
special gold award.
And if you see, my
copy has one award.
But if you look at Duncan's
copy, it has three awards.
Can you hold that up for them?
Okay, so these children have learned
about book awards because I've kind
of been trying to explain
to them what it's been
like to be on the committee.
And so another thing that happens
besides sending books to schools
and libraries is, when a
block is a very important book
for a particular group of people,
what group of people do you think
this book is most important for?
Delara?
>> Mexicans.
>> Mexicans who live in Mexico?
>> No, the Mexicans who
live in the United States.
>> Mexicans who live
in the United States.
Only Mexicans?
What do you think, Millon?
>> I think it's for people
who live around the world
that don't get good schools
in the United States.
>> Do you mean people from all
over the world who might not get
to go to the best schools?
>> Yeah, in the United States.
>> Okay, okay.
I don't want to take too much time
away from the author, because I talk
to you guys all the time.
But I just want to say that
one of the groups of people
that Duncan sent this book
to were three different --
or probably his publisher --
three different award committees.
And all the award committees said,
yes, this book deserves an award,
because it's such an important
story, and it's beautiful.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: And so
awards, I mean , it's very special
to receive an award, but it
also helps the book a lot.
Because what happens, every year in
the United States, there's thousands
of children's books
that get made, right.
But only a few of them, only a small
percentage, only a small amount,
talk about different
minority groups,
talk about African-American children
or Mexican-American children
or Asian-American children.
The amount of books that talk
about those people is very small.
So an award like this helps it --
helps more people find these books
and shows that these books are
good books and important books.
Because, you know, the United
States is such a diverse country
with different types of people,
that the books that get published
and get printed should also be
-- should also reflect that.
>> I think you have time
for three more questions.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yeah, there's the T-shirt I
made with one of my drawings.
Most of the T-shirts I wear
have my drawings on them.
But yeah, it's something that
I've done for several of my books.
So I've done -- this is my
fourth book that I've written
and illustrated, and
I have five books now.
Because I have a new book that
came out a couple weeks ago.
So I have five books that
I've written and illustrated.
And sometimes I get
invited by different --
to make the drawings
for a different author
who writes a story and
I make the pictures.
But I've done five that I've
written and illustrated myself.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Question ]
So what I do there -- so
in that machine, a scanner,
sometimes I put something, right.
Sometimes I'll put like my sweater
on it and then I'll see an image
of the texture of my sweater
on the computer screen,
and then I'll use that.
Other things, for example,
like the wheel of a tractor,
I can't put the wheel of a
tractor on top of the scanner.
So I'll take a photograph myself
or I'll go on the Internet
and I'll search pictures
of wheels of tractors,
and I'll find one that
I think will work.
And so by doing that, then I
use a program called Photoshop,
in which I can kind of cut things
and paste them in different areas,
and that's how I build
my illustrations.
Here in red, yes?
>> When you were talking to
Sylvia, when you wrote the book,
did you remember -- did she remember
you, that your name was Duncan?
And that she had actually
talked to you?
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Yeah.
So I learned about this
story from my editor,
the person that's kind
of like a teacher.
He was working with a different
author on a book that relates
to that case that I told, Brown
versus Board of Education.
And in there she mentioned the
Mendez case, this other author.
And then he said, oh, I think he
would be very interested in this,
because he knows I'm
very interested in issues
that affect Mexican-American
children and Latino children.
And so I said, oh, yeah,
this sounds very interesting.
And I looked online and I
found out more about it.
And then I happened to
be in the same place
where Sylvia Mendez was going to be.
And so I got to meet
her and talk to her,
and I told her I wanted
to make a book.
There's a different book that's
been made about Sylvia's story,
and there's been some documentaries.
There's a really great novel
called "Sylvia and Aki,"
which is like for kids
in middle school.
But I wanted to do a
book for younger readers.
And so I told her and
Sylvia said, oh,
it would be great if
you'd do the book.
If you make the book,
make sure I wear trenzas,
because I always wore trenzas like
that when I was a little girl.
And so then I wrote the book,
and then when I finished writing
the story, I actually visited her
in her home in California.
She lives in Fullerton, California,
very close to where she grew up.
And I showed her the story, to make
sure that everything was correct.
And those pictures that
included at the back
of the book are pictures
she showed me
and she gave me permission
to include in the book.
And so this book has
received several awards
and honorable mentions.
It received an award
some months ago,
an honorable mention
and Sylvia Mendez was
able to come to that.
And so I've seen her a few times
and I've had an opportunity to talk
with her, and she likes the
book and she's happy with it.
Yes?
>> What is the fifth book called?
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: So let me
show you really quickly some
of the other books.
I won't be able to read them to you
because I know we're
running out of time.
>> We have I believe "Diego Rivera,"
and also "Pancho Rabbit
and the Coyote."
So I can show you at
least two others.
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: And so then
I'll show you the latest one,
which is called "Funny Bones."
And so some books that I've
made are fiction, right.
There stories that I make up
with people that don't exist.
But other stories, like this
book, "Separate is Never Equal,"
and like this book,
"Funny Bones," are based --
are nonfiction, are
based on true people.
So this is the story of a man
named Posada, who was an artist.
And he made these drawings
of these skeletons.
And so wanted to learn, why
did he make these drawings
of skeletons riding bicycles
and dancing and playing guitars.
So the book is a biography of him.
I went to a library and
I learned about his life
and the different drawing
techniques that he learned,
different things that happened.
And it's also about the Day of the
Dead, because he made the drawings
for the Day of the Dead,
which is a holiday.
Maybe a lot of you know about it,
that happens just right
after Halloween.
And so in the book I
talk about different Day
of the Dead traditions, like
doing these paper cutouts
or like making these sugar
skulls or decorating shrines
with marigold flowers
and dead bread.
And then there's also this tradition
of writing calaveras poems.
And they're poems that involve
skeletons in some kind way.
So for example, this is
a calaveras poem I wrote.
It says, "it was a warm
afternoon in the middle of May.
Mr. Bones grabbed his hat
and went walking that day.
When he noticed a beauty
on the opposite street,
he ran towards her and
kneeled at her feet.
You're the prettiest girl
I've seen in my life.
Please marry me, please be my wife.
I am sorry, senor,
but that cannot be.
You're handsome and all,
but too skinny for me."
And so the poems are supposed
to be silly and funny.
And Posada, he drew -- he
made a lot of illustrations
for those kinds of poems.
So in the book, I put his
illustrations and I ask questions
about why he drew those
images and try to think
of why he made those
images and ask questions
about why he may have done that.
And so that's the latest
book I've done.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Is anyone in the school [inaudible].
In this book, in "Separate
is Never Equal"?
Well, the main character,
Sylvia, she's still alive.
I forget exactly how old she is now,
but she's in her 70s,
close to being 80.
And her brothers are still alive.
Her parents passed
away some years ago.
And what happened is when Sylvia,
after she went to the school, right.
After she went to that school
with children of all races,
she went on to middle
school, high school,
she went to college,
and she became a nurse.
And she worked as a nurse for a
long time, for almost 30 years.
But then her mother got sick,
and so she stopped working
so she could take care
of her mother.
And when her mother was very
sick, she said, you know,
I'm so sad that no one knows
about our story and all the things
that we did to make it
so that children could
go to school together.
So Sylvia decided she was not
going to work as a nurse anymore
and that instead she was going
to start traveling and talking
with people about this case so more
people would find out about it.
And in that room were she
used to take care of her mom
when she was sick, now
it's kind of her office.
And she has all these awards
and all these different pictures
and recognitions for her
effort, for her family's effort
and for her effort so that more
people learn about this story
and to talk about education
and equality.
>> Kahin Mohammad: All right,
I want you guys to join me
in thanking Duncan Tonatiuh for
making time to come here today.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.